parla a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi dice sono soli gente oggi
dopo dopo anni che seguo più di pai che
lo copio e o successo il maestro il
sempai colui che ha inventato me mi ha
messo in un sorriso sono in un video di
più di file e la cosa è veramente
incredibile
allora cosa è successo quando io ho
fatto su youtube rewind
sapevo che lo youtube rewind sarebbe
stato un video visto in tutto il mondo
perché lo youtube rewind ogni anno è uno
dei video più visti in assoluto se non
il più visto non musicale adesso non lo
so e quindi pensavo che più di pai
all'inizio pensavo fosse proprio nel
rewind poi alla fine ho scoperto che non
era così
però ci ha fatto la reaction e quindi ci
sono anche io nel video tv fai adesso
devo far vedere il pezzo vi prego perché
è assurdo certi di buyer tutta la jont
rospi perfetto vorrei poi c'è più di fi
che fa reaction a tutto il rewind finché
finché non arriva la parte dove c'è il
sottoscritto che in realtà è molto
avanti vediamo la scena originale per sé
anche rewind con più di slide che si
credo che sia anche a riguardo i colpi
di click che esista io sono qui che sto
facendo delle mosse molto poco cose e
siamo tutti questi bei ragazzi
poi ci sono io che vado completamente
scollinato dalla parte opposta ma vabbè
con un altro discorso di non so ballare
amen e più ripagare il suo video fa
riesce arriva a questo punto qua perché
informato sugli altri cristo perché
perché hai fatto questa con ignoti così
tanto perché guarda guarda stavo
spuntando mi si vede pochissimo che si
vede per una frazione di secondo pro
piccolissima sono lì a zuma studiata c'è
ma cosa può fare una cosa o la prima
volta ho visto detto no non ci credo
affermato proprio nel punto dove c'ero
io e sarà un logo o reflex ma sai che ci
ho pensato anche io quando ho fatto
rewind che io avrei evitato di mettere
foreste dentro rewind questo almeno per
quest'anno ci avevo pensato un po che ti
parlano ovviamente lo ha detto niente
che erano tutti youtuber cioè la youtube
stessa
il signor youtube e non parliamo di
fuori di ogni altra roba eh vabbè poi
continua col video performance che ci
sono io ho completamente scordinato però
la mia vita adesso può finire non essere
spero di restaurare subito dopo quindi
ragazzi è fatta è fatta
ma va bene così va bene io sono una
persona contenta non voglio più fare
video io faccio sempre fatto video solo
per arrivare a questo punto da domani
smetto grazie a tutti
e stato un piacere non solo sono
comparsi nei video di pike tasto sta
facendo un bordello di vincennes
vabbè ma sono comparso anche se tu
scrivi rewind su reddit solo rewind qui
per parlare del rewind una delle scene
più discusse del rewind io compagno per
un se quello che avete visto è il mio la
mia parte del rewind quindi su otto
minuti di video conte che dura non mi
ricordo 8 minuti io compagnia per
quattro secondi in totale più o meno no
su otto minuti e 13 su quattro secondi
indovinate qual è la scena più discussa
di tutor rewind esattamente questa se
scrivi rewind anche su reddit una delle
scene più se non quella più discussa e
questa è questa qui perché dicono tutti
sono sempre scoordinatissima hanno messo
la foresta dei suicidi nel rewind ma non
hanno messo più di pace è per niente una
delle cose più negative di questo rewind
da parte del pubblico è stata proprio
che non ci hanno messo dentro più di pai
che sta avendo st mega battaglia contro
t series per chi avrà più iscritti e
questa doveva essere messo nel riguarda
assolutamente non l'hanno messo come non
hanno messo un sacco di altre cose hanno
messo un sacco di forti sono sempre
contento di finire in discorsi positivi
tipo disagio è bindi buon su youtube
reminder nate grazie io porto sempre
positività su youtube
fortunatamente tutti hanno guardato la
foresta del suicidio tutti hanno
guardato al fatto che è un rewind
orribile e quindi nessuno ha notato il
mio scoordinamento nel ballo
ringraziando gesù aggiungiamo dei
commenti su questa cosa dal secondo me
c'è questo è uno dei peggiori rewind che
youtube abbia fatto secondo me è un bel
video punto perché è un video della
madonna perché fatto benissimo perché
avranno stanziato non so quanti milioni
di dollari per fare rewind c'è solo la
mia stanza d'albergo la mia costava boh
non so quanto ho fatto una ripresa di
tre secondi
non so fare il 3 con la mano non solo
uno youtube quindi figuriamoci quanto
hanno speso per fare l'intero video
secondo me sui 5 10 milioni non lo so
pronto sacco avranno speso di migliore
ed è un peccato perché ci sono tante
cose secondo me che potevano migliorare
hanno dovuto farlo molto friendly family
policy ok ci stava
troppe cose boh non lo so ci sono un
sacco di punti di vista
a me personalmente al di là di che c'è
solo sono solo balli riforme al di là
delle policy al di là di tutto la cosa
mi è dispiaciuta di più è che questo mio
parere mio che tutti altri venderanno
volto più musicali invece in questo qua
c'è un punto di questo rewind parte che
dura un sacco ma c'è proprio un punto
dove non c'è musica c'è parlano che
palle
cioè si blocca proprio tutto il mood del
rewind di riguardo è sempre stato tipo
un videoclip musicale non so come
dirvelo
poi se fosse una canzone è qua non ti
rimane secondo me non rimane quasi nulla
di questo rewind quindi dislike non sono
per un qualche cosa in particolare
semplicemente un mix di cose che
potevano essere fatte meglio perché
quando comunque ho fatto la parte di
fornai ho detto cavolo c'è in tutto
rewind l'unica parte di four nights che
ci sarà la devo fare io cioè mi sembrava
assurdo e non era per quello era perché
la mia era una delle miliardi di parti
di fornet che era nel vino ci fosse
stata solo la mia sarebbe stato ok c'è
anche four nights per quei qualche
secondo invece no tutto il video ci sono
allusioni a four nights però vabbè
chissenefrega
speriamo anche nella prima parte chiusa
fatto comunque a parte fornita parte
tutto sono in un video
lo dico anch'io
si può dire che alla lontana ho recitato
con will smith ho ballato con comunque
ragazzi questo rewind alla fine è
diventato un po una sorta di me me
perché dal video stesso tirano fuori
meme su me e me prima di vedere i mm
degli altri volevo farvi vedere il mio
che mi sono auto fatto perchè meritava
un sacco se tu stoppi nel preciso
momento che ci sono io
esce questa immagine che io ho tramutato
in questo è bene quindi l'immagine la
trovate magari ve la lascio in
descrizione pulita quindi senza scritte
se volete trasformarla in un meme spread
the memes spread da fdj tra l'altro cosa
curiosissima hanno vestiti per fare
questa voce non sono andato vestito così
nel rewind ci sono i costumisti che ti
vestono decidono per coloro come farti
vestiti e come vedete qua per fatti
assomigliare punto personaggi di ford
ente cetera io avevo io avevo questi
pantaloni quano che sono molto forti
night style era l'unico indumento di
scena che non era di scena erano i miei
pantaloni era andato in e allora perché
ho registrato sta roba londra che ho
fatto anche il blog non so se avete
visto appena mi hanno visto con questi
addosso ha detto wow tu sembri sei già
vestito da fornet quindi ci mettiamo
solo la giacchetta e la felpa io mi
vesto tutti i giorni con personaggi ecco
perché non posso giocare perché mi ci
resto mi sta per esplodere l'orologio
quindi a parte il mio memec e che
secondo me merita e ricordatevi
mandatelo a tutti i vostri amici vostra
sorella vostra nonna
scriveteci qualcosa ovviamente volevo
vedere quelli che sono diventati imeem e
number one del rewind che secondo me
meritano la vita ok
direi che possiamo tutti un'altra
ragazza
spero che questo diventerà anche non
aveva fantastico sono molto contento di
essere finiti in un video libri bike
quindi vi ringrazio avrei preferito
essere non so se con più di paio con
will smith però l'importante è essere
scoordinati
la vita se siete scordati farete strada
è stata molto strano partecipare rewind
però nessuno di noi ha mai giocato a
four nights di quelli che sono lì
neanche io ero quello che ne sapeva di
più pensate come stavamo messi quindi va
bene saperlo ringrazio più di piper
questa opportunità che mi ha dato e
iscrivetevi a più di pike così almeno
con tra quanto sta messo contratti si
rispettano
porca vacca sta raggiungendo t series
ragazzi scrivete gli atti ripa
immediatamente sono scrivete che ha più
di pai così almeno maledizione stacca
ancora di più t series non devono
raggiungerlo ragazzi è impossibile ma ce
la possiamo fare
spero di sì ha preceduto ragazzi scrive
filippeschi e dirigenti che idea
ciccioli ai ministri non scherza se lo
sai come si schieri e noi ci vediamo ad
un prossimo video ragazzi bella ragazza
bella a tutti i ragazzi per la a tutti i
ragazzi
[Musica]